the jurgen experience one thing
that we're seeing with society and
culture in general and one thing that
sort of does support the idea of
maintaining these sort of rigid
disciplines is that
when things start to slide just a little
you lose like a
little these little incremental steps
they slide
and people go oh god what's the big deal
what do you care
and you're like i see where this is
going like i s there's
this is it's going down that way this is
not going to stop
it's sliding oh yeah and you saw it in
la i mean
i've lived in l.a my whole life and the
the move from
l.a being a pretty safe fairly nice city
suburban in orientation to just overrun
with with horror shows is really
it is a lot faster than i thought it
would be but it's sort of a you're right
it's a gradual decline and then it's
just off a cliff well you started to see
tents and you didn't see them at all for
decades and then all of a sudden i
started seeing tents i remember i was
doing fear factor in skid row
in the early 2000s we would film down
there and i'd be like this is crazy
like has anybody seen this does anybody
know this because there was these
homeless
streets like you go down these gigantic
and downtown l.a back then for people
don't live in la you would think oh
downtown's like downtown new york or
downtown cleveland
no downtown l.a was uh no man's land
nothing's going on in downtown l.a it is
now
like there's what was pre-covered
it was like there was some bars and
there was some really cool upscale
apartment buildings it was kind of
picking up
but uh i took my family there before
kovid like
a few four months before covert or so we
went to we were going to go to there's a
famous donut place there
so we said just uh one of the most goofy
sunday things like what do you guys want
to do today let's go get donuts
so we went to downtown l.a like holy
[ __ ] literally
[ __ ] human [ __ ] on the streets
everything smelled like piss bums
everywhere and i'm like okay
stay close to me stay over here if
anybody comes near you move
move closer to me like jesus christ like
this is crazy i don't want him to be
freaked out but i'm like this is
nuts well the thing is that that sort of
disaster area stuff in l.a was sort of
localized
right it really like i worked in the
lada's office for a summer when i was
when i was in law school it's been like
2007 so
a while ago and i remember they had a
giant tent city and you had to walk from
the car
they made you park a mile away and walk
it and so you're walking through skid
row
and it's like okay well this this is
really terrible and honestly i feel bad
for these people because i don't think
the best solution for people who are
drug addicted or mentally ill is to live
on the street and a heavy percentage of
people
who are homeless are drug addicted or
mentally ill but you know
is it for for people who are living in
the suburbs like this is at least
localized it's not like reaching into
your life
and then over the past 13 years like i
live in a pretty decent suburban area
and i'm seeing like open needles on the
street and walk out of my house one day
there's just a guy lying face down in
the gutter like edgar allan poe
and i thought well this is this is
falling apart rather quickly
what do you think caused the slide or
the expansion of the slide
because i agree with you that it was
very it was very
isolated skid row was very isolated
downtown l.a was very i remember one
time we were filming in downtown l.a
and we were on a gurney or i guess
that's what you call one of those things
called
where it lifts up oh anyway we're
filming some fear
factor stunt and as we got up we could
see people smoke and crack
and i go look there's people smoking
crack right there and the the guests
on the show like a lot of them they fly
from all over the country and they're
like is that real they're really smoking
crack going
that's crack that's a homeless person
smoking crack welcome to l.a
it's right there but i didn't feel bad
about it i felt like look
it's unfortunate but this is not like
indicative of all of la
we're just in a shitty spot because it's
really cheap to film here right here you
go
you know you got a little gift you get
to see some weird [ __ ] while you're here
but i didn't i didn't think it was ever
going to get
to the point where you're on like
winnetka off the 101
and there's 80 [ __ ] tents and they
put a porta potty there
they put a port-a-potty we're doing real
building and real development here in
los angeles
not apartment buildings we got some
porta-potties we put every underpass
shall have a port-a-potty
thanks to mayor eric garcetti you pay
attention to
politics far more than i do and and and
law enforcement and all that
what happened how did it get to this
well on this particular problem this
actually started with a bunch of
lawsuits so the lapd used to have the
authority to move people's [ __ ] if it
was on the sidewalk
if people had a bunch of stuff that was
on the sidewalk and they're just camping
out there the lapd could come and they
could take their stuff away
and they could rouse them or they could
arrest them for trespass or for
loitering
and then the aclu actually sued and they
said that this is a violation of
people's personal property
oh and the courts tell you you do such
good work sometimes and the court's
ruled that you actually are not allowed
to move people's stuff that that's
actually personal property
even though it's in a public area and
then they got a ruling from a court that
you're allowed to live in your car
because for a while you weren't allowed
to live in your car and then it was
you're allowed to live in your car
so now you're basically allowed to leave
your stuff on the sidewalk and the
police are not allowed to move it
and you're allowed to live in your car
and then
there was this sort of equity movement
that said okay well things get in
business districts but
why can't they do it in like more
suburban areas why can't they just move
into nicer areas after all if there's
misery it should be equally spread
across the city
and and that's kind of what you've seen
i mean this is there have been so many
breaking points over the last year in
the city and for me
for me and my wife i mean we looked at
the rioting and they shut down the
entire city at 6 pm it's a county of 12
million people
and they shut down the entire county so
that douchebags could run around
shattering windows pretending that they
were standing up for social justice
they shut down beverly hills at 1 00 pm
rodeo drive at 1pm
so that people could run up and down
rodeo drive talking about how capitalism
sucks while
tweeting from their iphone while
stealing stealing nikes